nous lançons trop cela tiendra le tiers
a cédé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chan je vois que vous avez des appareils
électroniques
[Musique]
j'ai fait un bisou en fait la
mobilisation pour la zone a commencé
hier six mois s'appelle comment au juste
l'enfant dormait le prénom bah non j'ai
pas coller une étiquette sur le front à
la naissance le but est de montrer qu'on
peut y vivent autrement j'ai jamais été
vacciné ma vie je n'ai jamais rien eu à
cacher un peu de sang dans les selles
razoux nathan entend aussi j'ai un
souffle au coeur proches puissent mais
c'est tout
moi j'ai un vrai problème que je voulais
partager avec vous depuis deux mois je
pus la châtre ses pointes à orthez et
les biscuits en cataplasme tu peux me
laisser infuser la nuit en bouquets à
l'intérieur son problème est qu'on peut
bien sûr bizarre la barricade venez voir
coller aux [ __ ] un accord probléme
hausse de gens me voient tout un tas de
gens morts sur la route
y'a plus personne sur twitter ce qui
reste ils vont co ² deux grammy parmi ça
me fait chier tu en as tu des parts
d'orthographe et twitter pandémie c'est
papin demi c'est pandémie il ya une
[ __ ] de pandémie des débiles formule
pandémie
[Musique]
là
reste calme
[Musique]
on garde son sang froid c'est la fin du
monde se reverra dans l'au-delà l'amour
et l'amitié plupart qu'une épidémie cas
de leurs chansons de the voice la fin du
monde en fait tu penses qu'elle vient
gens de télé réalité c'est la prod qui
vont voir il faudrait que tu fasses un
truc un peu ce serait que tu fasses
l'amour avec le plus beau reste de
l'aventuré
genre je cours je gagne que je gagne
ouais c'est un jeu s'amuse